тиждень є абсолютно принциповий і
визначальний для подальшого майбутнього
нашої держави і мова не йдеться лише про
те що за роки з 14го по 19-й Ми пройшли
дуже велику дорогу по євроінтеграції
насправді Це був час коли народжувалася
українська нація бо Хочу наголосити що в
14-му році на початку кількість
українців які підтримували членство
украї в НАТО Уявіть собі була
16% а зараз за
80 кількість українців які підтримували
євроінтеграцію
України
дорівнювала кількості українців які
підтримували інтеграцію в тайожний союз
33% зараз це майже 90 і це означає що
Україна повертається в європейську
родину е-е народів і повертається до
своєї історичної місії і чому цей
тиждень який буде є визначальним Ми до
нього дуже-дуже ретельно і активно
готувалися і не лише змінами до
Конституції і не лише надзвичайно
важливим безвізовим режимом А ми
проводили переговори для того щоби для
початку переговорів були підйомні
критерії для нас було виписано сім
критеріїв ее які сім кроків до ЄС Я
впевнений що якщо ви зараз Спитаєте
половину урядовців і т/чрті
парламентарів щоб вони перелічили які
саме сім кроків від нас виписано для
початку
переговорів точно не назвуть і
принципова позиція - це формування
конституційного суду за участю провідних
європейських правових експертів бо
констиційний суд - Це найвища судова
інстанція держава і питання про боротьбу
з відмиванням грошей і питання про
інвестиційний клімат і питання про
незалежність антикорупційних органів
включно з формуванням сапу і всі ці
питання які вибудовуються вони були
можливими їх зробити за
тиждень скільки ми їх робили і оце є
яскравою демонстрацією того що не всі у
владі налаштовані на серйозну кропітку
дуже цілеспрямовану роботу і Отже що я
чекаю 8го числа 8 листопада я не просто
чекаю Я
знаю що буде оголошено про рішення
єврокомісії про початок PR accession
talkк початок переговорів про вступ і це
не є ще завершення цього процесу Бо у
нас зали ться до грудня місяць і ми
маємо переконати кожного з членів
Євросоюзу для того щоби на засідання
Ради Європейського Союзу лідери держав
та урядів підтримали євроінтеграційні
прагнення нашої держави бо для нас Це
питання
життя як я цитую слова одного з
прем'єр-міністрів країн-членів
ЄС каже
НАТО - це життя це безпека а
ЄС - це краще життя І от на сьогоднішній
день нам потрібні обидві ці позиції Хочу
наголосити що два тижні тому під час
зустрічі з комісарами єврокомісії і з
комісаром по розширенню
із комісарами включно з
віце-президентами єврокомісії ми знімали
останні штрихи заперечення Бо коли вже
опозиція які вони нас називають вимагає
щоби ми знімали будь-які застереження
для них це дуже вагомий аргумент А ми
показали вміння грати єдиною командою
проводити міжпарламентську демократію
про яку щойно говорили в вашій студії
проводити демократію спілкування з
виконавчими органами І сьогодні ми що
можемо впевнено заявити
завтра в Києві буде урсула фондерляйнен
величезний друг України вона привезе і
наголосить попередній проект рішення а
8го числа в наступному тижні це буде
оприлюднено Україна зробить ще один
великий вагомий крок для європейської
інтеграції Я не
хочу там
якось там передбачати події але можу
наголосити це означає що лише величезний
обсяг роботи у нас попереду яку ми маємо
зробити Протягом наступних місяців бо
мова йдеться про копенгагенські критерії
критерії яким Країна має відповідати і
сьогодні величезна відповідальність
залежить від уряду величезна
відповідальність залежить від парламенту
і величезна відповідальність залежить
від Волі президента І лише об'єднавши ці
зусилля і про це Я переконаний завтра
скажуть ла лише об'єднавши цю зусилля ми
можемо вийти на результат результат
грудня у вигляді рішення Європейської
ради і результат Коли Україна зміниться
настільки щоби відповідати
копенгагенським критеріям критерії
складаються з чотирьох позицій перша
позиція - це критерії політичні Яке
перше слово в політичних критеріях
Свобода
демократія права
людини права і захист Незалежності
ЗМІ верховенство права це вже другий
критерії які забезпечує судові критерії
економічні критерії рівень розвитку
економіки різень життя людей і над всім
цим нам треба працювати дуже напружено
для того щоби отримати необхідний
результат Петро олексійовичу зміни які
вимагає ЄС вони чіткі зрозумілі і най
вони корисні для самої країни для
України от ви сказали верховенство права
боротьба з корупцією Свобода слова я
чесно не розумію як цей критерій
виконаний Свобода слова Як ви можете
оцінити рівень виконання кожного
критерія до до 100% навряд чи дотягуємо
до
50 Це залежно від того хто оцінює окремі
наші урядовці кажуть та ми вже все
викинали все викинали і над ними
сміються в єврокомісії в брюселі в
єврораді і в європарламенті просто
сміються боце не повага до роботи
європейських
інституцій є конкретні практичні засоби
застосування якщо пані Світлана
дозволить мені я Хочу наголосити існує з
червня місяця рішення суду яке остаточно
оскарженню не
підлягає де наголошується що всі
кримінальні справи які були
започатковані за кляузами
портнова були порушені проти прямого
каналу мають бути закриті як
безпідставні червень липень серпень
вересень жовтень листопад півроку
рішення суду не виконується і ніхто не
притягнений до
відповідальності що це означає це
ставлення до свободи сло слова і
ставлення до верховенства
права позавчора прийнято рішення
верховним судом України
що державна влада діяла в незаконний
спосіб коли не випускала вашого
покорного слугу як члена делегації
парламентської асамблеї
НАТО на пункті пропуску незважаючи на те
що всі необхідні документи були я не
розумію А чому Це я маю питати дозвіл в
якогось
бюрократа мені мене цей бюрократ на
посаду не призначав мене обрав
український народ і лише перед
українським народом Я маю тримати звіт в
абсолютно неконституційний спосіб були
прийняті рішення про обмеження
політичної діяльності народного депутата
Порошенка Гончаренка інших народних
депутатів з нашої фракції ці і От вчора
верховний суд прийняв історичне рішення
ви дієте
незаконно і навіть якщо потім вас
випустили ті хто вас не випускав мають
бути притягнуті до
відповідальності і От коли в нас буде
верховенство права коли буде ру ofло і
коли
такі Я не заперечую все може відбутися А
коли такі випадки будуть предметом уваги
глави держави
як гаранта конституції і як людина яка
безпосередньо відповідає за темпи нашого
вступу я щиро бажаю щоб саме так і
було ми будемо демонструвати прогрес в
цьому напрямку але поки що можна
засвідчити от власне про те що ви
сказали так щодо прямого телеканалу щодо
того що вас не випускали рішення судів є
а реакції жодної
немає
Але я думаю що тут ще ми маємо додати
має бути незворотня відповідальність
суддів які приймають незаконні рішення і
це має дуже серйозний вплив на всі сфери
життя від інвестиційного клімату до прав
людини від Свободи ЗМІ до демократії в
країні і у нас на сьогоднішній день на
жаль залишається нереформовани те що ми
встигли реформувати це є верховний суд і
ви антикорупційний суд ще так сяк працює
те що суди першої інстанції суди
апеляції залишаються нереформованими а в
них зараз чітка вимога сформуйте вищу
Раду правосуддя заведіть іноземних
експертів сформуйте вищу кваліфікаційну
комісію суддій і забезпечте незалежне
судочинство незалежне від кого від
дзвінків з офісу президента від тиску
правоохоронних органів і від того що
судді знаходяться на гачку захищаючи
абсолютно брутальні недемократичні і
незаконні вимоги і от сьогодні ще раз
кажу моя мета не критикувати владу
навпаки моя мета ми маємо розуміти що
стоїть попереду що зараз стоїть в дуже
невеличкому часі відкриття вікна
можливостій і сказати що нічого
важливішого за нашу перемогу за наш
вступ ЄС за наш вступ НАТО нічого
важливішого не існує Петро олексійвич
важливе запитання от що робити з тими
країнами які от не дуже хочуть бачити
Україну в Євросоюзі які аргументи можуть
переконати які аргументи знайти для
Угорщини і
Словаччини Дайте я скажу вам сенсаційну
річ в нас не існує країн
які прагнуть зупинити
рух України в ЄС та нато не існують і це
я вам кажу
як людина яка 5ть років проводив
переговори по Найбільш важливим
євроінтеграційним питанням для України
наприклад ви назвали лідера Угорщини
Віктора
Орбана можете подивитися анти
іміграційну політику яку проводила
Угорщина в 14му 15му 16му і 17му роках
Це було питання політичного прапора його
політичної сили і дуже непросто було
отримати
рішення Угорщини на раді міністрів
внутрішніх справ коли ми билися
за безвізовий режим і рішення самого
Віктора Орбана але коли ти ведешпере
говори коли ти використовуєш весь спектр
аргументів мотивацій і рішень коли за
тобою стоїть вся потужна команда
Європейського союзу ти точно отримуєш
результат Я маю досвід переговорів з
Віктором орбаном Я маю досвід
переговорів з фіцо словацьким
прем'єр-міністром бо він не перший раз
прем'єр-міністр і свого часу Нам вдалось
отримувати дуже важливі рішення від
Словаччини і це стосувалося і поставок
зброї Ми дуже відкрито Це не коментували
Але можу наголосити що Словаччина ще за
моїх часів була дуже активним учасником
постачання дуже дефіцитної радянської
зброї яка зберігалася на її арсеналах і
мож наголосити
рух нашої народженої нації де 90 від за
європейський союз та нато не зупинити
нікому з лідерів країн Європейського
Союзу чому Бо більшість громадян
Європейського Союзу вважають що Україна
склала можливо і український народ і
українська нація склала можливо
найважчий екзамен на право перебувати в
Європейському Союзі і більше половини
європейців гаряче підтримують членство
України ЄС та нато ми там будемо І це
залежить
е-е темпи наше залежать від нас самих ми
маємо не давати підстав нам відмовляти і
це дуже-дуже-дуже важливий меседж Ми не
маємо права давати будь-кому казати ми
не Приймемо українців бо вони
корумпована нація бо в них є
неконтрольована корупція бо в них є
авторитарний режим бо в них є тиск на
свободу слова бо в них є заборона на
функціонування політичних партій і
закриття роту парламенту чи опозиції ми
цього не можемо собі дозволити дуже
висока ціна дуже висока ставка стоїть
зараз на Кану і коли ми якраз говоримо
про високу ціну от я не можу не запитати
ви вчора були на фронті відвозили
допомогу нашим воїнам які нас боронять і
чим вони сьогодні живуть от яка ситуація
на фронті чого нам очікувати найближчим
часом і особливо в контексті якраз тих
статей які вийшли в таких виданнях
журналах я Time і The
economist не можу не запитати питання це
цікаво Ну я хочу сказати що я кожен
тиждень буваю на фронті і це не є
екскурсійні
поїздки це поїздки до бригад з якими ми
маємо вже майже з ким д два роки досвіду
з ким три з ким чотири А з ким і вісі і
девть років
ее особливо з нашими десантно-штурмовими
бригадами бригадами морської піхоти
окремими сухопутними бригадами з
камбрігами які я знав ще командирами
роти і батальйонів і Це прямий діалог
для того щоб Ми вирішували найбільш
гострі питання які стоять перед
бригадами які неповоротлива державна
бюрократична машина не здатна вирішити а
Від цього залежить життя
здоров'я
настрій наших воїнів І лише вчора ми
привезли потужний комплекс з трьох
птахів станції машини пункту управління
посійдон його отримала президентська
бригада і його отримала 22 бригада вони
вже мають досвіти можу наголосити що ті
бригади які
були озброєні цими комплексами знали про
рух росіян в полосі їхнього наступу все
і встигли побудувати
оборону це дуже круто Вчора ми привезли
перше 50 fpv Дронів нашому ее бойовому
побратиму
ее позивний підлий з він зараз
керівництві 131го батальйону окремого
розвідувательного оперативного
командування і ми були вражені е нам
приїхали бійці яких Ми давно знаємо і
нам продемонстрували просто механізми
застосування fpv і можу сказати що
незважаючи на найважчі часи під авдївкою
де в тому числі і вони воюють
е втрати Росії там дуже важко там дуже
гаряче там неймовірно і дуже важливо щоб
ми зараз це розуміли І Поставили це
першим пріоритетом чим ми можемо
допомогти нашим воїном
і я можу наголосити що кількість втрат
які зараз зазнають росіяни під авдеївкою
вони вже відмовились майже від
використання бронетехніки для штурмів бо
наші арта до речі сьогодні
свято День ракетних войск і артилерії
хочу скористатися Ні ми це
називаємо днем богів богів війни бо саме
так називав це бабіч наш бойовий
побратим і я можу наголосити що наша
арта дуже вправно працює і дуже
ефективно знищує бронетехніку яка
сунеться на наші
позиції були привезені ще для 10го
корпусу п'ять банно-пральних комплексів
буде привезено для окремих розбідбатів
включно з 74м пересувні авторемонтні
майстерні були привезені для восьмого
полка Спецназу як він колишній називався
також нова техніка для 148ї бригади
артилерійської бригади
десантно-штурмових військ
також окремі подарунки
і це ти там незважаючи на те що дуже
втомлені воїни незважаючи на те що їм
дуже важко ти там заряджаєшся енергією
ти там Розумієш І це головна функція
головний вид діяльності який зараз має
бути у всі всіх українців бо сидіти на
дивані і стверджувати я вірю збройним
силам вірити треба в Бога а збройним
силам треба допомагати треба посилювати
їх міць робити все від тебе залежне для
того щоби це було не дарма і
ви
дуже правильно запитали про статті і
статю в times і статю в The economist
залужного на фронті про них знають на
фронті дуже уважно про них
читають на фронті готові їх
обговорювати
Але звичайно набагато активніше є
дискусія в
політичному експертному середовищі в
Україні я можу сказати свою дуже коротку
оцінку цих
статей по-перше їх не можна
критикувати це все рівно як спроба
арестовича чи хто там у них тоді був чи
зараз є відключати засобі масової
інформації і отримати інформацію тільки
з єдиного марафону йому вже ніхто не
вірить це є не просто теплована а зелене
заткле
болото яке заважає об'єктивно оцінювати
реальність так от про що стверж
демонструє стаття В
С всередині влади є
криза причини цієї кризи треба окремо
аналізувати і кризу треба
долати це дуже велика розкіш
мати конфлікти
всередині Я абсолютно не радію цьому бо
це робить нашу державу слабше А ми маємо
зараз бути сильніше і єдність має бути
не навколо думки єдиного марафона чи
думки якогось подаляка який До речі яки
дуже безглуздо коментує це а єдність має
бути навколо збройних сил України і тут
у нас нема жодної дискусії бо авторитет
збройних сил України є надзвичайно
високий А про що стверджуть ессе
залужного в The economist мож наголосити
вона стверджують про
роз спробу розмовляти з західним світом
бо стаття спрямована вперш за все на
західне середовище дуже дорослою
правдивою компетентною і відповідальною
мовою і ця мова стверджує про те що
потенціал контрнаступу
вичерпаний що є ризик переходу до
позиційної війни
що допустити цього ми не можемо бо
позиційна війна вона вигідна росіянам
які
абсолютно не звертають уваги на людські
втрати перебудували свою економіку на
військові рейки і на сьогоднішній день
втрати які несе Україна Нехай навіть
росіяни несуть більше втрат але вони
мають більший мобілізаційний ресурс ці
втрати на це позиційна війна на користь
Росії і це була позиція не політика
це позиція
військового і Він стверджує що нам треба
терміново перейти від позиційної до
маневреної
війни і для цього що треба зробити там
абсолютно чітко
сказано і я думаю що армія виконає це
завдання і ми зможемо аргументувати
перед нашими партнерами що нам
треба збільшити поставки але там ще й
друга
позиція уряд має Збільши
власне
виробництво зброї яку наголосив залужний
це є засобі радіоелектронної боротьби і
Хочу наголосити що нами протягом
останніх двох тижнів прийнято рішення
профінансувати 150 млні грвень за
рахунок власних коштів для виготовлення
суперсучасного засобу радіоелектронної
боротьби і я дуже щасливий бо ми пройшли
перше випробування
дослідницького зразка бо це інвестиції в
ніокр і ми посадили перші два в бойових
умовах російських безпілотника які
координували ланцеети це свято для мене
і так само
налагоджуємо підвищення якості
виробництва оперативно-тактичних
безпілотних літальних апаратів
виробництво техніки включно з
броньованою і все включно до речі згу
розмінуванням І це все що каже Залужне
але це частина завдання для уряду і тоді
запитання А чому уряд цим не займався 5
років чому уряд зупиняв програми
військово-промислового комплексу чому
якась аудиторська служба зупинила і
банкрутує
підприємства які
виробляють найкращі зразки нашої зброї
які інколи перевищують
західні відповідь дуже
проста ми маємо вивчити досвід
Ізраїлю і коли Ізраїль в перші
години штурму
хамас 7мого жовтня вийшов з ініціативою
Що ми робимо уряд національної єдності
це не
коаліція це означає що це є
технократичний
уряд професіоналів уряд дорослий уряд
який здатний змінити це
все і там там можуть бути і посади
міністрів без портфелів але це не є уряд
для посад це є уряд для відповідальності
бо всі політичні сили в парламенті мають
розділити відповідальність тут не має
бути опозиції розділити відповідальність
за результати роботи цього
уряду я би дуже хотів щоби цей досвід
був почутий це вимога в статті була
почута бо якісь завдання стоять перед
солдатами Всі розуміють і вони
надважкі не просто забезпечити наступ і
звільнити території України а зберегти
державу і солдати мають займатися своєю
воїнською почесною справою А що маємо
робити урядовці парламентарі
президент Вони мають Забезпечити свою
перемогу І що це за
перемога це означає що нам треба встати
з окопів позиційної війни по нашому
просуванню в ЄС та
НАТО і перейти в Контрнаступ по руху
України в ЄС та НАТО це те для чого
обрали чого чекають І що зобов'язані
зробити всі би без виключення органи
влади на парламент лягає величезна
частина відповідальності на уряд лягає
величезна частина відповідальності і на
президента і коли ми говоримо про це це
не тільки щоб парламент приймав закони
це не тільки сформувати негайно після
початку переговорної групи після
відкриття переговорів pracession talkк
до Європейського Союзу там мають бути
експерти там мають бути переговорники
там мають бути авторитетні люди яких
знають в Сполучених Штатах по з питань
НАТО і в Європейському Союзі і у нас
немає іншої альтернативи бо це є наш
наступ Контрнаступ в напрямку то
членство в ЄС та НАТО це є наша зброя і
врешті-решт це є наша перемога бо Коли
мене запитають А що є в цьому сенсі наша
перемога от членство в НАТО є нашою
перемогою Бо це буде забезпечувати
англійською мовою sustainable Security
situation тобто сталою безпековою
ситуацією на континенті і це точно
означає поразку Росії от про НАТО хотіла
вас запитати чи бачите ви Петре
олексійовичу що вікно можливостей для
України відкрите щодо НАТО і Чи повинні
ці два процеси бути синхронізовані вступ
НАТО і в ЄС і в чому ризик якщо вони не
бу будуть
синхронізовані відповідь така вони не
можуть не бути
синхронізовані якщо ви візьмете
вимоги до України для вступу в ЄС і
вимоги для України для вступу в НАТО ви
будете здивовані бо вони співпадають на
95%. і там і там верховенство права і
там і там демократія і там і там свобода
і там і там економічні критерії до НАТО
додаються певні безпекові критерії які
вже зараз з'являю в критеріях для
Європейського союзу а щодо вікна
можливостій Лариса ви абсолютно праві
тільки я би не казав що зараз вони
відкриті хоча це так А я би хотів
сказати що вони дуже швидко
закриються
і невідомо на який час вони закриються
але якщо бути відвертим вони можуть бути
закрит на ціле
покоління
аргументація можете собі уявити що
наступного року серед наших партнерів
або від тих кого залежить вступ України
в ЄС та НАТО в 43х країнах або
об'єднаннях відбуваються вибори від
Європарламенту до Сполучених Штатів
Америки від основних
країн-членів Європейського Союзу аж до
тайваню і після виборів ситуація буде
змінена Я не кажу що вікно закриється
але воно буде важче Бо нам треба довести
чому виділення допомоги Україні для
Великої Британії 5 млрд фунтів важливіше
за будівництво моста в
Манчестері і це мають розуміти політики
британські Вони мають іти з сім до
британських виборців це абсолютно
очевидно та сама ситуація починаючи від
Німеччини завершуючи сполученими штатами
але не треба нікого
лякати цими виборами я можу наголосити
що під час своєї каденції я починав
діалог з
трампом мене всі
лякали і я можу наголосити що моя перша
моя Перша розмова з трампом була серед
перших 10 країн які яким позвонив
Трамп і замість 5ти
хвилин
реверансів ми говорили 45 хвилин з
трампом коли був мій візит до Вашингтона
передбачалося йхн на 5 хвилин бо графік
президента трампа був дуже розписаний
ми працювали
годину і я можу наголосити що на
сьогоднішній день
не таких перешкод які не може Україна
подолати просто не існує бо від цього
зале
чи залишиться Україна чи ні Бо саме це
поставлено на карту і я не маю жодного
сумніву що ми переможемо і немає жодного
сумніву що залишиться але Леву частину
роботи ми маємо зробити вже і зараз не в
24-му а вже І зараз я хочу наголосити що
всі критерії по НАТО ми маємо виконувати
і відправляти всім країнам членам ми
маємо запрошувати їх представників для
оцінки прогресу і ми маємо заробити
максимум можливого для того щоби в
Вашингтоні влітку Наступного року ми
отримали не один а два документ перший
документ - це
запрошення за яке проголосують всі
країни-члени і для того щоб вони
проголосували наші депутати наші
парламентарі наші експерти наші
активісти наші урядовці і
президент мають працювати з кож країною
членом кого ми знаємо їхати переконувати
заручатися їх підтримкою для того щоб
підготувати
е саміт і коли нам кажуть Слухайте ну не
всім подобається що ви гово говорите про
НАТО Я не хочу цього чути бо ми говоримо
і діємо в інтересах України і коли всі
зрозуміють включно з нашими партнерами
що
мир і перемога неможливі без членства
України в НАТО в них з'являться
додатковий аргумент а друга позиція це є
додатково до запрошення нам треба не
ніякий не Security ance запевнення в
безпеки яким ми Отак Сити в
будапештському меморандумі я це знаю на
власній шкірі А ми маємо вивчити і
використовувати досвід Швеції і фінля
де надаються справжні ратифіковані
гарантії і
гарантії які будуть діяти до нашого
членства І от запрошення та гарантії є
завданням по нашій
європейсько-атлантичній інтеграції
питання геополітичне складається
враження так і є Не складається враження
Україна разом із союзниками на світлій
стороні протистоїть
осі Росія Іран
Китай протистояння глобальне як в ньому
Україні
перемогти Я думаю що
вже років п'ять я ніколи з вами Лариси
не сперечався зараз
будете
вимушений по-перше Хочу наголосити ларис
оцей російський наратив що існує
глобальний південь що
існує весь
вісь Росія Іран Китай ну
благаю виключить Китай з цієї вісиі бо
він не є членом цієї вісі Китай не
проросійський і уж тим більше не про
іранський Китай прокитайський і нам
треба бути дуже переконливими щоби найти
китайський інтерес в перемозі
України Це не є перемога Сполучених
Штатів чи перемога НАТО це має бути
перемога Китаю бо Китай Торговельна
держава і війна дуже рішуче перешкоджає
китайській економіки яка
уповільнюється я це знаю що це можливо
тому що я сам мав декілька зустрічей з
президентом
сідзеньпінім і у нас був дуже гарний
Діалог і тоді коли мені казали що після
переобрання сідзеньпіня Порошенко
привітав
сідзеньпіня і це викликало хвилю
обурення я заявив Почекайте
півроку Ви ще будете стукати в двері
Китая і зараз коли на Мальту представник
Китаю не приїхав
що є дуже поганим знаком це
означає що ми недостатньо Працюємо з
Китаєм а вісь зла у вигляді Росії
Північної Кореї і можливо Ірану ми
подолаємо ми відірвали Індію від цих
діалогів Я дуже сподіваюся на успішну
зустріч зньпіня і байдена в листопаді
яка має відбутися і про неї оголосили і
ми переможемо
ми це не є гіпноз такий знаєте ми в
будь-якому разі ми переможемо тому що ми
вміємо бити росіян наша позиція в світі
має бути переконливою і ми маємо
яскравим чином продемонструвати що ми
б'ємося за суверенітет територіальну
цілісність незалежність але й за свободу
демократію економічний розсвід і
інвестиційний клімат верховенство права
і інші позиції Бо це буде перемога
демократії і Свободи над авторитаризмом
і диктаторством Путіна і це
знаєте маємо показати що після програшу
наприклад в
Афганістані має бути виграш в Україні і
так має
бути Петро Олексійович дуже важливе
запитання знову ж таки не можу не
поставити це економічне запитання так А
ви зокрема зокрема якраз коли говорили
про копенгагенські критерії говорили і
про економіку для нас для всіх для
українців надзвичайно важливо чи можливо
підняти економіку під час війни
орієнтуємося на фактичні абсолютно
офіційні дані а щомісячному опитуванні
національним банком підприємств
український бізнес погіршив індекс
очікувань ділової активності да це лише
один із таких моментів Але чи можливо
все ж таки підняти економіку під час
війни Я знаю що у вас є відповідь на це
запитання
Я думаю що ви задаєте це запитання
правильної
людині Я Хочу наголосити що в 14-му році
коли було
найважче коли було падіння ВВП яка
вимірювалася більше
10%ками коли був ноль золотовалютних
резервів коли був ноль на рахунках в
казначийстві коли був шок з зовнішніми
ринками коли Росія закрила для нас свої
ринки а економіка була
неадаптована здавалося нездійсненною
мрією що вже з 15го року ми
продемонструємо економічне зростання яке
на піку вийде за 4% але ми це
продемонстрували і за рахунок чого
Спитаєте ви це дуже дуже просто і
складно
одночасно з 15-го року
ПДВ повертається
атично
корупційна схема державних закупівель
була подолана через застосування системи
prozoro корупція в наку корупція в
Укрнафті корупція В усіх державних
монополіях була викорінена за рахунок
застосування іноземних експертів
спостережних рад які зробили всі ці
монополії прибутковими
все це
зруйновано
економіка не витримає
згвалтувань тому всі реформи які були
проведені треба
повернути заборону Маски шоу це є перше
з чого треба почати заборону всім
правоохоронним органам на гарматний
постріл наближатися до суб'єктів
господарювання ми маємо відновити має
бути
одна структура
податкова яка має контролювати виконання
лише однієї позиції сплати податків це є
головна
функція суб'єкта господарювання і
якщо хтось намагається прийти захопити
заарештувати рахунки рейдерським образом
за
захоплювати власні
підприємства Кара має бути
невідворотньою і вона
буде бо той Жах який зараз відбувається
з рейдерським захоплюванням з арештом
рахунків з
абсолютно
брутальними сценаріями за участю суддів
прокурорів люди вихаркають кров'ю за це
тому що зараз важко Вони легко
розкидалися причинами що друзі Так у нас
скінченний потік грошей з боку наших
західних партнерів нас податкові
надходження не цікавлять
Ні це дуже швидко
закінчиться А ще виклик новий яких не
було за моїх часів це є нестача робочої
сили кваліфікованиї
мотивованиї і поки що я не бачу програми
як це долати але я знаю як і я гото
запропонувати цю програму і не можна
чекати що ми спочатку переможемо а потім
будемо займатися інвестиційним кліматом
Ні тому що якщо ви розраховуєте що за
рахунок публічних фінансів платники
податків країн наших партнерів повністю
профінансують всі наші бюджетні видатки
послухайте те що зараз звучить в
конгресі вони
кажуть зброю ми профінансуємо військо
видатки ми профінансуємо військову
допомогу також але фінансувати дефіцит
бюджету Ви маєте нам пояснити чому і
як і ми маємо розраховувати на
макрофінансову допомогу Європейського
Союзу ми маємо розраховувати
на допомогу в фінансуванні з боку
міжнародного валютного фонду але
Прочитайте уважно на кожній з цих
позицій стоїть умова
conditional тобто під певні
умови і ніхто загравати з нами не буде
Тобто нам щепити зуби і робити
своє і коли зараз розглядається низка
законопроектів які
передбачають збільшення перевірок
збільшення податкового
навантаження тим хто є ідейним
натхненником цих позицій Я хочу щоб вони
уважно почитали
я бачив це в київпості Вибачте що якщо я
використовую для реклами я не дуже часто
читаю но це побачив декілька статей Де
написано
Україна перетворилася в T Hell податкове
пекло і навіть Росія стоїть зараз на
декілька сходинок вище за Україну з
таким
е бекграундом ми ніколи не залучимо
прямі іноземні інвестиції
і врешті-решт я хочу щоб ми згадали кому
ми
вдячні за нашу можливість забезпечити
європейсько євроатлантично інтеграцію от
Я Хочу наголосити як Один із лідерів
революції гідності як Один із лідерів
Майдану Я Хочу наголосити що це
відбувається і відбулося не завдяки
Порошенко зеленському чи будь-кому
іншому це відбувається завдяки
українському народові народові який не
прийняв позицію Януковича про відмову
від європейської інтеграції народу який
став на захист в 14му році країни від
російської агресії народу який
народився і сьогодні
90% підтримає європейську євроатлантичну
інтеграцію і
ніхто ніколи і ніяк не зможе зупинити
цей
народ абсолютно Петро Олексійович Дуже
дякуємо вам що знайшли час що ми змогли
поставити вам запитання Наступного разу
сподіваємося АА на більше відповідей
тому що будемо ставити більше запитань
на більше вашого часу Насправді те що ви
сказали ми завжди завершуємо От наші
ефіри на наших каналах по-різному Да але
у нас одна суть Що Ми віримо в
український народ Ми віримо в нашу
перемогу і ми обов'язково будемо членами
ЄС та НАТО та тому що ми українці ми
найсильніші і ми Українці Ми завжди
переможці я хочу сказати Вибачте я Я вже
вже мала прощатися з глядачами Ні вам
Даю слово перед тим тоді дякую позиція
перша світа віри
недостатньо нам треба перти
плуга перша увага і слова вдячності
волонтерам друзі ми з вами робимо дуже
круту справу ми маємо продовжувати Хоча
я знаю що зараз працювати з кожним з
Днем важче і важче менше грошей
залишається в людей все ми маємо це
зробити Ми маємо вимагати від уряду не
забирати гроші в солдат в бригад
виконувати всі зобов'язання Бо нічого
важливішого за воєнні видатки зараз
немає і третя позиція ще раз ми маємо
встати з окопів і позиційну війну в
напрямок євросоюза перетворити в
маневрений наступ
Контрнаступ в бік Європейського Союзу
Української держави без цього
ее жодні інші позиції немають жодного
сенсу Ну що ж дякую вам за ці слова
Петре олексійовичу за це інтерв'ю і я
хочу подякувати глядачам п'ятого і
прямого які Ці дві години були з нами Ми
Свій маленький внесок робимо зараз і
будемо робити для того щоб Україна була
в Європейському Союзі і НАТО тільки
спільними зусиллями і трудом ми там
будемо ще раз Всім дякую за увагу
спасибі
[музика]
дякую